hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna just checking in on you how are you
how's it going Jesus Christ good news
the according to the USA Today the CDC
Center for Disease Control said that uh
the coulvet virus does not spread easily
on hard surfaces or in surfaces or
whatever right
that's a good thing now for all you
mouth-breathing morons out there they
didn't say that it doesn't spread they
said it doesn't spread easily you know
like you can bend over and tie your
shoes but can you do it easily right if
someone were to play the audio of you
tying your shoes would people would
people be like would they guess you're
tying your shoes is that what they would
guess or would they guess it was some
sort of assault happening number one
reason to stay in shape and so when you
go to [ __ ] put on and off your shoes
you're not going
face turning all [ __ ] red seeing
those black splotches right before you
pass out and then you do a [ __ ]
handle right then that's it now the
whole family can't go out to all about
they can't go anymore
why why can't they go I'll tell you why
cuz you got two goddamn [ __ ]
out-of-shape you went to tie your
goddamn ax who Kim whose can't go when
you get that out of shape that's when
you just get the Vans right you get the
slip ease slip them on slip them off
right Greatest Generation though they
still wore the velcro straps you know
they didn't like they didn't like the
[ __ ] slippers it was too easy for you
know that's when you wear the slippers
you wear the slippers when you get too
goddamn fat to put your [ __ ] let me
come on what's wrong with you you know
you got a root you got to record
yourself when you're trying to tie your
[ __ ] shoes okay do you want to be
making those [ __ ] noises you don't
want to be doing that go out and have a
garden salad you know what I have been
doing this is what I've been doing so I
got all these healthy [ __ ] recipes
and everything and as great as it is to
eat healthy you know cooking three meals
a day for yourself sucks right what am i
[ __ ] chef tell over here I don't want
to [ __ ] do it all the time so what
you did what I do is right now when I go
out I get the groceries I come back and
I put everything away then I immediately
make like a breakfast a lunch in a
dinner that'll last for like four or
five days and I stick them in a giant
[ __ ] Tupperware and then and whenever
it's time to eat I walk to the
refrigerator like a [ __ ] zombie I
dump it in the pot I heat it up and then
I eat it and then I'm done it's kind of
the way to go I have this healthy
chicken fajita like soup thing that I
make and then I got these turkey burgers
a little bit of spinach in there and
this taco seasoning and then I got these
these egg cups with you put them in like
it's a mixture that you put a little egg
white in there it's a mushroom broccoli
onion and a feta cheese then you just
pour them in like a muffin tray third of
a cup and each stick them in the oven
and there's your breakfast for the [ __ ]
a week I'm not gonna lie to you it does
get boring but it's it's also it's an
it's an easy way to stay on your diet if
you if you are trying to lose weight cuz
I know I come hard I come down hard on
the fatties you know some people they go
after Isis other people go after Harvey
Weinstein I go after the fatties and I
think that that's what makes the world
great is that you know you can never can
relax there's always somebody coming
after you no matter how good a person
you are I've learned that watching these
animal videos you know we're sitting
here [ __ ] [ __ ] moaning and
complaining about staying in our houses
and our apartments and if you just look
out the window
alright every animal you see
for the most part is gonna get murdered
like if they had insect basic-cable
you know and you know the first 48 first
of all their lives aren't even 48 hours
the first 48 [ __ ] seconds or
something like the amount of them that
get killed I actually saw a baby
praying mantis on the hood of my car the
other day it was wasn't even the size of
my mic like fingernail it would think
was amazing those things are scary as
[ __ ] and you stick them in a jar and
they just [ __ ] you know you need Joe
Rogan and those guys this [ __ ]
announced what goes down next that's
their [ __ ] octagon you put him in the
jar and there's some pit if there's two
males or two females I forget what they
just go at it and then one of them gets
the other one in a headlock with their
[ __ ] those basically the pliers that
they have on the front with the teeth
and [ __ ] they just [ __ ] snap the head
off and that's it something like that
happens I have no idea
I've been still watching those animal
videos there's a good animal video out
there animals that [ __ ] with the wrong
animal somehow a raccoon got in this
[ __ ] zoo cage with these [ __ ]
chimps and they would just [ __ ] with
this thing and then when they were done
with it there's one just just ever so
slightly the way I would fling a sheet
of paper across the room it would go
maybe two feet just grab this [ __ ]
thing and just threw it like a frisbee
and the thing was like on its back with
all four legs out you know I think I you
could count maybe five or six rotations
and then it landed on its back down at
the bottom and it tried to run through a
drain and then then it was a game they
ran down they [ __ ] pulled it back out
again
I don't know was [ __ ] chimps man who
knew all my whole life they were
considered cute you put him in a little
suit with that [ __ ] hat right you had
him for a pet and then one person gets
their face ripped off and the next thing
you know everybody's looking at him in a
different way I actually worked with a
guy who got attacked by a monkey
a long time ago I had this gig in one of
the writers in there had this crazy
tattoo of a monkey on his arm and he
told this crazy told a story about I
think he was a kid he got attacked by a
monkey he went up and there was some
[ __ ] organ grinder or some [ __ ] you
know with the balloons or something and
you go to give the monkey like a nickel
I don't know what happened I don't know
what the nomination this guy tried to
give the monkey but the monkey wasn't
having it and just [ __ ] bit him or
some [ __ ] right so he was telling me
ever since then every time he works with
the monkey he [ __ ] stays away from it
and he was talking about when he was
writing for commercials you know
commercials that's like that's the
number one acting gig monkeys get you
know they're gonna be in a [ __ ]
commercial you know there was the heyday
was the late 70s when Clint Eastwood was
sort of between Dirty Harry and the
Unforgiven and he made those monkey
movies that was a good time but he only
liked the orangutan which my whole life
I thought it was orangutan like the
drink you know that the astronauts
allegedly [ __ ] drank I don't think
they did I just think everybody at NASA
bought stock and tang but anyway he was
saying that basically this is for
anybody who's in the business like three
or four takes the monkeys cool and then
it starts to get a little nuts and then
after about a half-hour the monkeys just
gonna do whatever the [ __ ] it wants it's
it's over it you know it's not
interested in getting its sag card it
doesn't give a [ __ ] if the movie does
well that's that's a deal breaker
you ever think about that [ __ ] oh you
know what I didn't get any [ __ ]
emails maybe I got some emails I said
check I really liked that that question
of basically what it was a band that has
a huge hit but you think they actually
have another song that's better also
known as a deep cut or whatever people
[ __ ] say let me see if I got any
goddamn things here I have no idea I was
watching a bunch of NFL I watched the
1950 NFL championship game the
highlights Curt Gowdy hosted this show
and they
like all the guys on there Luke Rosa
Otto Graham didn't have Marian motley
though I was kind of hoping he was there
running back who I guess was one of the
great running backs before Jim Brown and
he had a great football mind and wanted
to get into coaching and they just
wouldn't give him an opportunity at all
that's the one thing you know when you
go back and you look up the players back
the level of racism back then was just
[ __ ] brutal that's saying that people
aren't racist now you know but like you
can get a job right I guess I'm white
what the [ __ ] do I know
but I'm just saying like this guy lived
he went back to was it Art Modell and he
just said no there's just no openings
and then he hired some guy that wasn't
you know less experienced wasn't as
qualified and then Art Modell was like
well we have quote 12 Negroes on the
team this year that was like his defense
was [ __ ] ridiculous so anyway but
they have footage of all of these games
just sort of watching them and you know
that whole theory that all they did was
just run the [ __ ] ball is [ __ ]
they threw it a lot the game I was
watching both the Rams and the Cleveland
Browns were throwing it a whole bunch
and I actually read this really cool
comment on the YouTube page this guy was
saying you know they say the greatest
game ever played 1958 the Colts first
the Giants in Yankee Stadium and that's
the thing that put the NFL on the map
and all that blah blah blah blah blah no
one ever talks about the 1950
championship game that was won on a
last-second kick by Lou that togh Rosa
de Rosa and they said that the reason
why that game didn't get as much
attention is because that was the Browns
first year in the league and the NFL the
whole time the all-american football
conference was around they were calling
it a Mickey Mouse League and saying it
wasn't professional so it was a really
bad look for the NFL that the first year
one of the expansion teams the one that
won all four titles and I imagine they
were going like yeah they came over here
they lose to the worst team
miss Mickey Mouse [ __ ] League see you
know whatever they were saying they came
in and they during the regular season
they defeated the two-time defending
champion Philadelphia Eagles and then
they came in and defeated the former
Cleveland Rams
that was another thing another part of
the drama was it was the All American
Football Conference team that drew more
than the Cleveland Rams so they left to
go to LA to become the Los Angeles Rams
and now they were coming back to kick
the ass of the team that drove him out
of town
in the inferior league and they came in
and what happened they didn't get the
all right there Fred they did at the end
of the game so this person was saying
that the reason why this game doesn't
get as much attention is because it was
a bad look for the NFL it was
embarrassing and the 1958 game
was a better look for them because even
though it was the Colts it was the NFL
Colts it wasn't the All American
Football Conference Colts that folded
like a year after they got into the NFL
it was the rebooted Colts I think they
came back in 1953 Jesus Christ bill what
the [ __ ] do you want from me it's a
goddamn pandemic so the Rams had a
quarterback called Bob water-filled and
the Browns obviously had Otto Graham
those were the two starting quarterbacks
and Marion motley one of the great
running backs forgotten name I swear to
God at some point I'm gonna I'm gonna
[ __ ] pitch a show in the NFL Network
where old ass bill talks about old ass
football because people should know this
[ __ ] all right so anyway plowing ahead
here Joey beat Joe bark Nick gave me a
this book called the code about I don't
know the code and in professional hockey
and how it works fighting sticking up
for yourself and showing up answering
the bell and all that it's absolutely
fascinating the game within the game and
but I have to be honest with you as a
lifelong NHL fan and a huge fan of the
fights
I've always found it bizarre that the
NHL was basically if we don't let the
players police themselves the games
gonna get out of hand that doesn't make
any sense to me every other league has
been able to make rules and if people
break rules and hurt somebody you get
thrown out of the league I think that
that would cure all of that stuff for
those like now you don't understand
they're skating around they got clubs in
their hands you got to let them handle
this [ __ ] I would as much as I'm reading
this book I just I think you just have
to be a professional hockey player to
understand it I mean I'm glad it happens
but what's cool is they take some of the
bigger fights and some of the bigger
hits and some of the uglier moments in
the game that Todd Bertuzzi hit against
Steve Moore and they talk about how
24-hour Sports network's just show the
hit and then everybody shits all over
hockey and they you know they don't kind
of show what led up to it not saying
that would make people feel any
differently but they kind of just make
it seem like this guy just went up and
punched this guy when he wasn't looking
and then pushed him down to the ice and
broke his [ __ ] neck it's it's like
there was a bunch of [ __ ] that led up to
that and according to this book after
you read the book you will watch hockey
in a different way I don't know how you
keep all those scenarios in your head
though every little slight you know that
happens anything that one player
considers that another player did was
dirty
they just file it in the back of their
head and when they get a [ __ ] chance
they [ __ ] hit the guy so who knows
you mean that you could play like two
three times and the games are too
important and the score is too close and
he can't take a dump penalty you just
bide your time that's Steve Moore that
poor kid he basically he hit the captain
on the Vancouver Canucks was that clean
hits borderline a hit so he knew that he
was going to have to you know fight at
some points the next time they played
are two times later he ended up
Matt Cooke and evidently he lost but
they didn't feel he lost enough so I
think that that's why when Bart Uzi was
asking him to fight he was skating away
like I already fought I'm done which
pissed you know Bart Uzi off and then he
[ __ ] punched in the hole blown all
the [ __ ] happened so you might want
to check out that book right sorry can
you tell that I'm [ __ ] reading while
I'm also looking at all of this [ __ ] so
anyway I have regrouped once again with
my stupid [ __ ] drum practice Jesus
Christ this [ __ ] good times bad times
think it's the reason why it's defeated
me for 30 years is because I simply lack
the patience to just sit at a certain
BPM until I get it down
totally and move on I just I get
goal-oriented right where I'm just like
okay it's played at this BPM I'm at this
BPM I would like to be at this BPM
within 10 PPM's by the end of the week
and I just get into that mode and rather
than just being like hey dude you can't
play it that fast yet play it at this
[ __ ] speed so I'm finally doing that
and it's I've regrouped and it's it's
happening for me and what I had to do
because the faster I was playing it the
more I would get lost in the fill
because it's weird as well it's this
sixteenth note triplet thing he does
between his hand and his foot and he
does it 10 times in a row and I know he
puts the backbeat in there but I just
get I would get lost in it and I'd put
the the beat the backbeat on like the
end of one or the end of two I would
just [ __ ] the whole thing up right so I
finally I slowed it down for anybody
else trying to figure this thing out and
then I just broke the fill into I count
four I count four again and then I count
two so it's 1 & 2
and three and four and one and two and
three and four and oh one end to end and
then you done and on the fourth that's
where the backbeat is one in a two
hundred three in a backbeat one in a two
hundred three in a backbeat wanting it
to win a bull you done took me forever
to fight I sit there be like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with me and what's the
greatest thing to was ere all these
frustrating days out there in the garage
trying to get it a little bit faster is
all of these people you know I don't
even think that they know it bugs me but
if they're trolling me it's it's it's
[ __ ] hilarious and my hats off to you
is they keep sending me that clip of
that Japanese girl I think she's
Japanese I don't know what she's like
eight years old and she's apt just
[ __ ] rips through the song big smile
on her face you know like like it's
absolutely nothing so I'm gonna do this
podcast and I'm going right back out to
the [ __ ] garage again I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm sticking with this thing oh
and also you know I gave Steve Gadd
credit for playing drums on that Jim
Croce song and now I just was reading
something else I think it's this other
guy hang on a second Jim Croce drummer I
got to make sure I get this guy's name
right who is Jim Croce's drummer but
Baba where the [ __ ] is it now come on
it was Jim Croce's drummer alright let's
click on this thing where is it Steve
Gadd did a lot of those cuts now there
was another guy wasn't Gary Chester oh
that guy Rick Rick Marotta and I watched
him play live and there's a lot of
overlap in his style and Steve Gadd
style while they're two completely
different drums and that guy look him up
Rick ma ro TTA absolute beast of a
drummer so I don't know who played it
the song that I'm thinking of if you
guys can figure out who played it's
working at the carwash blues it's a
silly song
but the drums that are played on that
track just [ __ ] blow me away it's
that first fill like eight nine seconds
in that little buzz roll thing between
his uh his hands and his bass drum and
then what I love is he keep repeats that
that phrase throughout the song it's
just this it's ridiculously tasteful
drumming so anyway I was washing dishes
this morning right the [ __ ] house
husband that I am now and I actually was
reminded of a bit that I done months ago
back when you could go out and do this
thing called stand-up comedy and I
couldn't remember once I thought of the
line I couldn't remember how the rest of
the joke went and I'm like wow this is
gonna be I should make a [ __ ] set
list of jokes that I can remember that I
did maybe walk around
muttering them in my backyard I mean if
your guitar player and you don't play
guitar for [ __ ] six months you know I
remember hearing Jimmy Page when John
Bonham died he was so depressed he
didn't play guitar he said long enough
that I kind of forgot how to do it which
I'm sure you know he had muscle memory
and stuff but like it was kind of scary
so I was talking to Burke Russia and he
said that he recorded his act right
before the whole thing went down I wish
I had done that whatever I'll get it
back and you know Tony V taught me if he
can't remember the joke then it was time
to stop doing it anyways alright so
there you go so I gave you a drummer you
should know Rick Marotta and then up NFL
football player you should know Marion
motley and then also another quarterback
Bob water-filled
you should look these guys up man the
[ __ ] games are great they're great
[ __ ] games and you look at the
Cleveland Browns that first year they
had like white helmets and it was before
when the helmets were starting to get a
little more sophisticated
and I remember as a kid looking at some
old football books and I remember at one
point there was a facemask that was
clear let me see this here evolution of
the football helmet tell me this [ __ ]
thing doesn't listen to you alright
the evolution of the football helmet
here's a video here eight [ __ ] minute
helmets through the decade 1 minute 17
this is perfect all right here we go
what's up guys hey guys you're not gonna
believe
lianca believe what I'm selling hang on
a second all right here we go
1920s she had the leather helmets all
right
this is cool this is called through the
decades football helmet check this out
on YouTube 1950s then they had the hard
plastic it was like it was a Speed Racer
helmet this is the one like Otto Graham
and all of those guys wore initially
when they get when do they get the clear
fiberglass across it the next one is oh
then 1950s then there was a clear
fiberglass thing almost like a hockey
shield over your eyes all the Colts had
a cool helmet with it with it with the
the horseshoe wasn't on the side they
had to on the back of the helmet on
either side of the stripe almost like
where they were where they would put the
number nowadays late 1950s then they
then they came with that with the actual
face mask one bar this guy has all cold
helmets then the 1970s then they came
with that grey face mask and then from
here on out you pretty much know what
happens isn't that interesting
1980s then the face mask matched the
helmet for the most part sort of a
precursor to the rush 1990s then the
Colts had the [ __ ] blue face mask
with the white I want to say Payton wore
that one didn't he mm I don't know what
the difference is now and let's see here
the 2010 so that's when you get all like
the [ __ ] the hood scoops and all of
that [ __ ] in there
well then that [ __ ] interesting Jesus
so yeah I cleaned up the whole house
yesterday got major props from my wife I
[ __ ] went in I went in i vacuumed I
scrubbed I had a mop the [ __ ] bucket
the whole goddamn thing my back was
killing me by the end of it that's how
old I am
back-breaking work to me at this point
is cleaning a house just sweeping up and
all of that [ __ ] I guess you could tell
you I actually [ __ ] enjoyed it I put
on you know I told you guys that that
band jellyfish spilt milk one of the
greatest albums of the 1990s and also
the balls it took to put that out when
they did I put that on and just I
listened to it back to back and I was
done with the whole [ __ ] house a
couple hours I was done
tremendous tremendous album check that
out and then lastly but Lisa Lee here
before I wrap this up I want to thank
the guys over at at barstool sports KFC
radio for having me on they actually
watched the the movie and they they
actually had complimentary things to say
I was I was you know I was you know
[ __ ] you never know you never know
how people are gonna gonna take it so I
don't know that was a big thing I figure
for like who the audience is for that
movie to have the guys at barstool
sports at least on KFC radio actually
watch it and enjoy the movie made me
very happy and very excited for when
this thing comes out so we shall see
like I said it's going to be streaming
and all of that [ __ ] so OJ Simpson has
significantly more friends than you
think
then you and I is that what you tell him
I don't want to click on that I know
there must be something KFC radio anyway
alright so that's it that's all I got
that's all I got for you thank you so
much for listening to the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast people out there if you
make
a little bit of money try to go to some
small businesses restaurants toy stores
anything you know have you got a niece
or nephew or a kid that needs a gift or
something like that try to spend some
money at these places I actually heard
the Troubadour here in LA legendary
legendary music venue and like you know
Richard Pryor's don't stand up there
Steve Martin I've read stories about
them doing shows over there and there
would just be a shame so normally what
we would do at all things comedy is
start a benefit or something I just
don't know how to do a [ __ ] benefit
well I guess we could do like a zoom
thing I don't know hopefully this this
thing will be over soon I I got nothing
guys I'm just I'm trying to be [ __ ]
positive here all right wait let's look
up Italy is it over in Italy yet is any
plate can it be over anywhere because
then people would just [ __ ] travel
and fly in there won't they Italy
Kovach cases all right I'm on the case
for you guys here we go
what bet that bad doo doo doo dude man
those [ __ ] they're killing it
new cases they went for let's see zero
before March they peaked at 6500 and
then May 16th oh yeah there they're like
they got like 1500 new cases so they're
doing a great job over there it seems
wait a second now here's something else
this total case is 228,000 recovered a
hundred and thirty-five thousand deaths
thirty-two thousand four hundred eighty
six well that means there's a bunch of
people sitting in beds over there I hope
they're all right
thirty-two thousand four hundred eighty
six deaths Guatemala angry over corona
virus infected two poor T's I mean
that's that's really important you know
to send some infected people even if
they are illegals it's like you know
what are we doing all right let's see us
cases granted we have more people u.s.
kuroh
virus cases what do we got here what
have we got here oh yeah 1.6 million
we're always the best with a [ __ ]
best at everything three hundred three
thousand recovered 94612 not a good city
if there's a [ __ ] outbreak Doha New
Jersey 149 Illinois California has
eighty one thousand seven ninety five
well that's the whole state of New York
by the way three fifty three let's see
lost Los Angeles let's see if I Los
Angeles let's get some stats here can't
all just be an old NFL football can it
look at this [ __ ] we had none and then
we went all the way up we we actually
plummeted below a thousand and then
spiked up to two thousand on April 18th
then we've dropped back down below two
thousand and then it just keeps going up
and down up and down up and down between
one and two thousand now alright so
confirmed eighty 1795 three thousand
three hundred thirty four deaths
it's a great recovery isn't it what
percent what three thousand three no
four is what percentage of eighty 1795
how the [ __ ] do you do percentages I
always just break it down to ten so ten
twenty thirty
eighty so let's see here eight divided
by I can't [ __ ] I don't know I don't
know what it is let's see at a hundred
percent that would be three point three
percent right it's less than three point
three percent do it that way all right
here we go how to do percentages thirty
percent of what is sixty 0.3 times blank
equals sixty so he goes sixty divided by
three wait that's not that's not the way
I want to do it though percentages
percentages made easy here's another one
for you
to look at percentage calculator this
the Chico dad you gotta get a percentage
calculator yeah it's got a flat-screen
TV on it did alright that's it everybody
I don't know according to our doctor
like we're gonna be parents again
any day now any day now so we shall see
we'll see if it goes full-term or if it
comes early we shall see we shall
freakin see I shouldn't say eat hit
right so he if he comes early or if he
comes right on time my daughter came
right on time
bing-bang-boom and I went I was a
full-term baby too
I was a big Baio I was a big baby I'm a
lot of people would say I'm still a big
baby maybe that was a theme you know
there's not one cute picture of me as a
baby you know I wasn't cute until I was
like maybe three or four years old but
like when I was like I like I said I
look like I was about ready to attack a
lego city when I was born just a big
giant I don't know what you would call
me trying to think what I look like
it wasn't the Michelin Man the baby
version it was more like a I look like a
silent film star a bald silent film star
that's what the [ __ ] I look like and you
know what that's what I look like today
alright I also did a an episode of the
virzi effect Paul Varghese podcast I
don't know when he's gonna post that
thing look for that it did a video thing
we talked late last night I was a little
tired so I'm looking like [ __ ] so I'm
sure I'll get plenty of emails telling
me that alright
I have drums to play and [ __ ] food to
cook
I got nothing people I just want to go
back to a world where you could go out
and get a root beer float with somebody
okay that's it please enjoy this music
and then we'll have another episode
after hear bonus episode of a greatest
hits just Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast
that is all I will talk to you have a
great weekend you [ __ ] hey what's going
on it's bill burr and it's the Monday
morning podcast for Monday the hell
month is it May 21st 2012 what's going
on how are you did you have a nice
weekend are you looking it's a memorial
day do my buddies got a [ __ ] boat kid
we're gonna get out there with some
[ __ ] Boy wises dude guys we can [ __ ]
the ladies
yeah that's coming up right I had no
idea I had no idea that next week was a
three-day weekend you know because I'm a
comedian
every weeks a three-day weekend you know
I don't have [ __ ] to do I just sit
around now actually I've been working my
ass off I just did you know I didn't but
I've got offered to do another episode
of Glee they liked what I did so much
last season it's a possibility it's not
a definite all right so I'm already
going to my vocal coach you know just
working out some songs you know I'm a
dreamer you know they probably turned
that into like a melody right they'd
start singing that then they'd go into
another one right ahead run away hi
why do they always do that then the
crowd always goes oh my god it's the
difference I didn't see that they they
they connect all those years I have both
those songs in my iPod I just never saw
how they connected it took a bunch of
Twinkletoes and a cafeteria to show them
they are we singing in the cafeteria
what is the deal with that what's the
deal with gay people singing a goober
dude
is there something for my my gay
listeners out there do you guys do you
guys feel the need to sing whenever
you're in a cafeteria I said what it is
you know come up to
football players semi bent at the waist
snapping your fingers moving your arms
vertically do you of course you don't
alright isn't that TV's version of what
you do you just like us you're looking
for a closet to rub one out again except
you think a different [ __ ] see that
bringing people together on the podcast
speaking of singing I'm gonna order this
thing you guys know that I hate country
music you know I like the oldest [ __ ] I
don't like the new stuff where they just
pander to their audience you know what I
mean I like America puppies you don't
like it we're gonna put a boot your ass
or whatever that [ __ ] jerk-off is
with the hat pulled down over his face
almost like he's ashamed of what he's
singing Toby Keith Toby Keith that guy
he always has that hat you know pull
down low you know he's a man yet he's
wearing chaps I like that guy that guy
he's got a lot of like contradictions
you know what I mean
he's like you know rough-and-tumble guy
yet he's wearing chaps like the guy in
the Village People and he looks like a
racist yet his first name is Toby you
know which i think is a shout-out to
roots so you know I can't figure that
guy out anyway so I was watching this
this commercial they had like a hundred
and fifty of country music's greatest do
a it's you know Loretta lamb Dolly
Parton Conrad Twitty that was the only
guy I found creepy I don't know if he
was nervous that he was on TV but he
would not move a [ __ ] muscle on his
face and he had this just his big
[ __ ] I don't pork shoulder [ __ ]
head you know what I mean like if he had
shoulder of bison like the size that he
had big
walking you know just 40 years before
p90x no guy was doing cardio right all
you were doing was yanking your [ __ ]
pants up or pushing him down and he's
singing some [ __ ] song about some
girl he's with I can't I can't remember
how the whole metally went but it was
something to the effect of you know I
can tell when I hold you but you never
been this far before something like that
it was you had something to do with him
holding this trembling virgin in his
arms as he sat there with this [ __ ]
600 yard stare like he's waiting for
Charlie to come over the [ __ ] wire
you know or let like maybe he was like
confessing to being a sexual predator
and like he was just waiting for the FBI
to come out and just arrest him in the
middle of singing that song you know
like after a while you just want to get
caught isn't that something that they do
I'm not saying that he's a sex offender
I wouldn't say that all I can say is
before he got his perm he looked like
one you know he had that Elvis just
going straight back but just a giant
[ __ ] head just a huge head you know
he looked like he looked like he was
already murdered and was fished out of a
lake just a [ __ ] bloated gigantic
head and he wasn't moving he looked like
that that [ __ ] thing one of the first
men in black alright bill we got it he's
got an awful head well [ __ ] you I got a
whole hour to fill here I'm only six
minutes in see you do it huh in your
cubicle somebody sent me the creepiest
creepiest email last week they said day
you know do you ever know anybody who
jerked up in a cubicle dot dot dot well
now you do you know and it's not that he
jerked off in a cubicle it's the fact
that he emailed me his name his email
all of that [ __ ] it's just like I mean
you're playing a dangerous game maybe
you want to get caught sir I would
you habitually jerk off and your [ __ ]
cubicle what if that went to the wrong
person but if you sent that to your boss
and he just got done yelling at you
saying you need to need to show some
initiative 20 minutes later you know he
gets an email from yet he's like alright
maybe maybe it finally stuck and I don't
have to fire this guy and he opens it up
and he it says a she ever know what he
buddy jerked off on a cubicle dot dot
dot well now you do
maybe he meant to send it to his boss I
mean that was his way of going out you
know just [ __ ] impregnated his laptop
and walked out now there's no way he did
that how could you ever get another job
there's no way around that anyways it's
Monday morning and I'm doing the podcast
and if you're new listeners I know what
you're thinking well I live and [ __ ]
Scandinavia and it's not Monday morning
over here listen I don't care I don't
give a [ __ ]
the only Monday morning I care about is
in my timezone it's 917 in the morning
all right those douche bags on those
morning shows are still on being sassy
showing spunk you know those are all
morning words you know what I mean
nobody has get up and go at 6 p.m. right
that's all that's all 6 a.m. [ __ ] she
she's just a firecracker right nobody
says that if 5 p.m.
around quittin time you know we just why
do I owe these you know what this
podcast is just me me stating the
[ __ ] obvious how much for a drive
yesterday and my Prius
somebody actually somehow redneck guy
was talking about my Prius Cohen you
know them things they don't know they
don't do want to think for the
environment you realize that don't you
mean them batteries and batteries they
put them cars do you know how long it
takes for them to break down let me tell
you they're doing act they're actually
they're actually doing more damage than
a regular gas combustion car you know
telling me all that [ __ ] you know I mean
half of its true the other half he's
like making up as he's going along you
know almost like he's talking about the
big
game then he never played it in high
school but there's no one around that he
went to school with so now he's
quarterback right
and I know as a lot of people listening
right now going that's actually true
all right I don't give a [ __ ] okay I
never said I was saving the plant did I
I don't think I did I probably did I'm
hypocritical I said there's nothing
everybody should be you know if there
was the right amount of human beings on
this planet we could all drive tanks and
it would have no effect on the ozone
layer all right
that's my new philosophy stop trying to
make cars have better gas mileage try to
have less people driving them no Jesus
is this my final solution it's too many
[ __ ] people people that's what the
problem is
all right it ain't the cars cars don't
kill the ozone layer people do um
anyways I get them into the biggest
dumbest [ __ ] fight last night with my
girl right we had this great day you
know was on the road again do you up Oh
hear that hit that bump up up that's
what I have to have it on for some
reason that's that noise that alert on
my phone doesn't freak out my dog but
every other sound on it freaks out my
dog and it starts [ __ ] shakin like a
goddamn junkie and that is an
embarrassing tone to have when you're
walking around with your friends you
know and it always comes on when you're
in the middle of some story that you're
exaggerating what you really did so I
walk up to the guy and I'm like nobody
[ __ ] you you want to take a [ __ ]
swing here I'll get me the first punch
right here buddy
bump bump bump bump bump ya know [ __ ] it
that goes down the goddamn toilet um so
anyways the hell did we do yesterday
we went out to brunch right
I already eaten breakfast so she got a
brunch and I got a beer
and some guy next to me with the big red
beard he'd been growing it for like nine
years it was like ZZ Top level I think a
little bit longer it was like reverse
Crystal Gayle you know like those like
the guy version of it except was a
redhead and so whatever and then I'm
like hey you know let's go for a drive
she's like I want to go to some shop
let's just walk down Street you know
that they grab your arm and you're just
sitting there you know I'm walking down
the street just thinking what if I just
elbowed her in the ribs and ran across
the street you know right to that [ __ ]
bar now it was actually a good time and
then after that I was like you know I
always fly out of LAX and I always see
the beach
and up in Malibu and Santa Barbara and
all that type of [ __ ] and I'm like you
know what we should [ __ ] check that
part of the city out so we drive over
there in the Prius that's not saving the
environment but getting great gas
mileage great gas mileage and we [ __ ]
get up there and what a bunch of douche
bags up there all right I gotta shut my
phone off what the [ __ ] bump bump what
the hell is it you know what that's just
gonna go off in the background let me
put it on mute here don't you wish there
was a mute button for people what's the
deal um yes we go up there what a bunch
of [ __ ] what a bunch of [ __ ] live in
[ __ ] Malibu I want to go up there and
I was trying to find like their town
centre I don't know if they have one or
what but every it's all gated
communities to keep out the riffraff
like me I can't even drive by and just
look at their houses you know so wait
how about whatever we're having a good
time we drive back we're going through
the canyons I pull over on the side of
the road we buy strawberries off some
guy who claims to be an organic farmer
right probably stole them from a Trader
Joe's who gives a [ __ ] right
everything's going great
so I stay in I take a night off from
comedy I say hey why don't we watch why
don't we watch a movie you know what I
mean
cap off this wonderful [ __ ] day
everything's going great what could go
wrong this is like the beginning of a
horror movie where they just show like
the perfect family and everything's
great and people are wearing like
white linen you know and then all of a
sudden they just start showing the
camera in the bushes like a POV of like
Mike Myers this is basically what
happened so 60 minutes comes on right
who doesn't want to watch that show and
pretend they're smart you know I like it
some more that Morley Safer comes on and
you know he smells like an old person
some old people don't smell like old
people but he looks like he smells like
an old person
you know smells of cigars ashtrays you
know a couple of wars maybe a date rape
so he's interviewing Meryl Streep all
right
the great Meryl Streep and they're going
through all oral oral frigging life and
all the movies and all the different
characters that she's played Oh first of
all they start they start the report off
with Morley Safer just sitting there
right smelling a [ __ ] bengay and
whiskey right and he says how you know
how over in England you know they you
know I don't know they make their
they're actors they award them by
calling them Lords and they Knight them
but over here at America all we do is
just give them the shiny statue and it's
just like starts off right off the bat
for some reason just [ __ ] on America
I don't know why like an Oscar is
somehow beneath Sir Anthony Michael Hall
I mean or or Lord what at Lord of what
what of what at least you can [ __ ]
hold our statue your Lord of what
kingdom that phony horseshit that you
have with Prince Charles and the popper
or whatever the [ __ ] is going on over
there you know look if the Rothschild
tonight you over there then that [ __ ]
means something then you can come become
part of their yacht convoy as they go
around the world figuring out how to
take over another currency right then
you're in with them okay but if you're
if you're [ __ ] you know Lord of this
and you're your wing man is the Duke of
Elton John I mean that's the whole thing
is [ __ ] stupid right so right off the
bat it's already bugging me but I know
Nia hates one
I talked to the TV right so I you know I
keep my big [ __ ] Yap shut
and they start talking about Meryl
Streep but papapapa going through the
whole thing and then the old guy they're
smelling of you know prescription meds
goes you know whenever they talk about
the roles you play they always say you
know you play independent minded women
very strong women and Meryl goes I know
that's yeah that's what they say you
know when a guy they never say to a guy
oh you're playing a strong-willed
character yada yada yada I let that go
whatever no biggie
I'll take that it's probably true the
[ __ ] do I know I'm not a woman right
but then they show her after she played
Margaret Thatcher and she's given a
speech to a bunch of women's young girls
she's trying to inspire them and she she
takes a quote from Margaret Thatcher and
it was something along the lines of if
you want a bunch of people to talk
around talk and stand around talking
about doing something you know something
to go to you got to talk to men but if
you wanted to actually get done you got
to get a woman and then all the chicks
go whoo-whee like flipping out right so
I laugh and I'm like a reverse sexism
right just seeing you know my whole
[ __ ] theory how everybody is just a
piece of [ __ ] you just don't have the
power to act out what the [ __ ] you want
to do because that's that right there if
you flip that around as a guy if you're
running for president it's [ __ ] over
you can't be like let me tell you no
tell you what after I get you jobs and
after I fix this economy okay and I'm
the man to do it because I'll tell you
right now if you're looking for someone
to stand around and talk about doing
something you get a woman you want to
get it done you got to get a man here in
my nuts right here on the podium vote
for me November 4th go [ __ ] yourself
right you did that your presidential
campaigns over she does it it's [ __ ]
adorable and it's just as [ __ ]
ignorant you know I mean what a [ __ ] do
you get off saying that we stand around
and do nothing
Meryl Streep huh or quoting Margaret and
you - Margaret Thatcher let me taste you
[ __ ] something all right we
faked a [ __ ] lunar landing okay you
think that's just talking anybody can
land on the [ __ ] moon
that's easy but to pretend you did it
all right and get everybody to shut the
[ __ ] up about it that that that that
right there that takes skill so whatever
so I make that little comment and did I
just go that that Dada Dada a silly
[ __ ] Porky Pig so so I make that
comment and like you know I've been with
me a long enough that I can tell by the
side of her face when she's just
thinking about like what if I just
grabbed everything I really cared about
and walked out of this house right now
she got like that [ __ ] mad at me you
know
and I'm like she's just like right after
the story was over she just shut the
[ __ ] thing off and I don't happen
next you know I'm walking to 7-eleven to
get some ice cream
I don't know what happened was all going
great you know I might be [ __ ] there
what am I am I supposed to just [ __ ]
sit there with my mouth hanging open
with drool coming out when I watch TV if
somebody says something douchey I'm not
supposed to say it yeah whatever
whatever so I just finally just said you
know what [ __ ] this I take the dog out I
go around the block what do I do I'm
calling my guy friends right they're all
backing me up
I'm not saying who I called I don't name
names all right and they're all laughing
their ass off and they 100% agree with
me which is all I'm looking for at this
point I just want people to say that I'm
right I don't want to learn anything
from this experience just tell me I was
right so I can be an ignorant ass again
I don't know why don't you guys weigh in
on that amaya dick for saying that
should I just let that one go you know
uh you know what she said that [ __ ]
drove me up the wall she goes why are
you she didn't say intimidated she was
one of those words why you threatened by
what she said I'm not threatened
Jesus Christ then I take the bait you
know it just sends me right over they
like threaten about what oh my god this
person that I don't know who has never
called me nor will ever
call me who has no effect on my life how
do you get threatened by that I'm just
calling it for the [ __ ] that it is
cuz you know what it this is what
[ __ ] drives me nuts I can't stand
when somebody tells me that their [ __ ]
sandwich tastes worse than my [ __ ]
sandwich okay
go [ __ ] yourself at what point am I
supposed to have empathy as I'm sitting
here eating a [ __ ] sandwich and you're
telling me how much worse yours yours is
you know at the end of the [ __ ] day
you know what I mean sure mine might be
on you know a better slice of bread
which I guess would make it taste a
little bit better but at the end of the
[ __ ] day right the end of the [ __ ]
day all right I'm gonna end up in a Fema
camp with you okay you think when the
next [ __ ] psycho comes along I'm
gonna make the cut what the [ __ ] do i
what do I bring to the world huh exactly
I don't be standing right next to you so
go [ __ ] yourself you just [ __ ] woman
every time she sneezes they give her
another goddamn award she's still
bitching still [ __ ] bitching you know
it's Richie I remember I did this
oscar-nominated part oh go [ __ ] yourself
with your wigs the whole thing just you
know that's what [ __ ] pisses me off
when I watch this [ __ ] if you really
want to know my perspective is from
where I come from
I can't [ __ ] about [ __ ] cuz that
buddy's like I'll go [ __ ] yourself you
hit the lottery
right but I gotta sit here and listen to
you [ __ ] even if you [ __ ] killing it
even if you're killing it you know Yale
School of Drama and you still killing
the bull
go [ __ ] yourself with your goddamn
yachts alright there you go let that
felt good
it's probably ignorant but whatever all
right let's get to uh let's get to some
advertising now that I trashed Lord
Meryl Streep what did what is she called
is she a prince princess is that what it
is you know if I ever get to that
[ __ ] level which God knows I'm not
going to because you have to have an
unbelievable body of work by the time
you're my age you know to even remotely
have a shot and then they're not gonna
give it to you until you're like [ __ ]
so that's that's out there that's out
the door that's like when I wanted to go
to Notre Dame when I was in high school
I wanted to go to that College and by my
sophomore year I knew that that dream
was over and so the same goes for ever
getting knighted but let's just say for
some [ __ ] reason they lower the
standards and I get knighted right or
asked to be knighted like that's some
[ __ ] I'm not showing up why would you
show up for that you know do you wanna
do you want to get knighted in our fake
Kingdom you know I don't know I'm gonna
get knighted by [ __ ] on mr. McFeely
is that what I'm gonna do
you [ __ ] weirdos why don't you guys
[ __ ] outside of your gene pool and then
maybe I'll show up to become a sergeant
and your little [ __ ] that's what
that's I'll hold that whole royal family
like a bunch of goddamn rednecks she's
my third cousin blimey that's why they
were all weird-looking Prince Charles is
a weird-looking son of a [ __ ] look at
his [ __ ] his awful teeth those ears he
really does he looks like he's missing
some parts you know what I mean he looks
like you know if you have like a [ __ ]
66 Mustang and then Yugi looks like the
piece of [ __ ] one that they're not gonna
restore and everybody you know very
going in there taking carburetors out
and radiators and [ __ ] he looks like
he's missing some stuff you know
princess diet was hot though she was hot
she had big feet though didn't she she
have big feet right now I'm losing
anybody gay listen to this
alright that's like their that's their
Jesus I think isn't it that [ __ ] why
do I try it
alright let's get on with the
advertising here what do we got here
what do we got oh let's go oh you know
what in honor of Memorial Day weekend
this is a big man holiday right we got
to sit there and act like you don't cry
sometimes do yourself late at night
what do we gonna do this weekend huh
you're gonna get some alcohol you gonna
rent a boat you're gonna hit a rock and
then say you didn't see it and then
there's gonna be some sort of big
insurance claim or you could stay on the
land and you can you can grill you know
and I'm not just saying what that normal
grill that you have that you've been
using for years with those little skinny
pretzel rod you know great state you
have on it you know what you need you
need the man great all right for this
weekend all right and if not for this
weekend you can do it for Father's Day
as the copy says yeah why don't you hook
up your dad for once your dad never gets
anything
okay this Father's Day there's only one
perfect gift all right because every
other gift you get him he's gonna throw
it in your face you want to get him this
right here it's the man great grill
enhancement system what's a man great
you ask well I'm glad you asked that
because I have the answers in this copy
right here man great shower a hundred
percent made America cast-iron grilling
grates all right and all you do is you
just take off your little pretzel rod
ones you don't I mean this is like
putting like you know yanking out the
awful engine and putting a bigger one
end all right you take off your old ones
and you slam this one down all right
there these are heavy-duty grilling
grades to deliver exactly what you need
to achieve the steakhouse flavor you've
been looking for the man greats patented
design chicken steaks or veggies will
have never tasted so good no more
flare-ups no more dry meant you mean no
more dry meat guaranteed take advantage
of our $20 Monday morning podcast
special today by clicking on the man
great banner at billboard.com as a bonus
every billboard com order comes with a
heavy-duty man great grilling brush all
right they're made in America they're
cast iron it's really cool man they got
like these these little catches so when
the grease comes down it stays in like a
little moat there so it doesn't flare up
and cause uneven cooking in that type of
thing and you know the deal
okay this weekend or giving it to your
dad you want to make the best steak on
the block it's it's a guy thing
it taps into the caveman in every man
okay and you got your dad
came up when guys were guys so he's
gonna love it alright its Steak House
quality grilling in your backyard you
get $20 off you go to billboard.com you
click on the podcast page and you'll see
the man great thing you click on that
you get $20 off there you go let's hook
up dad for once huh does your dad stand
around and talk about grilling a steak
and then your mom comes in and gets it
done I don't think so
Margaret Thatcher anyways you know
something Margaret Thatcher in that that
chick who view the original cook on TV
they look the exact same as far as I'm
concerned you know and Meryl Streep got
she won awards for both parts you know
what I mean
and she's still complaining you know
what she wasn't really complaining she
brought it at one point I totally blew
it out of proportion and that's what the
[ __ ] I do all right all right so now
that III I did a little advertising
there there's a couple of things that I
actually want to bring up that have
nothing to do with advertising just a to
awesome YouTube channels that that I
found you know now that I got a house
and I've been trying to learn how to fix
[ __ ] because you feel like a [ __ ] you
know when some other guy has to come
over and rescue you from your problems
that dude el cheapo I tweeted about this
guy I'm gonna have a link to one of his
is his YouTube channel is the [ __ ] this
guy can fix anything
plays guitar this guy he's like the
MacGyver
he's like a bargain-basement MacGyver I
don't mean he's bargain-basement
I mean he can do anything for like no
money he does everything for cheap and
believe me after you're in a house or
something like that or if you got a [ __ ]
job and the bankers are [ __ ] you in
the ass
this guy will show you how to fix
anything for cheap it's the [ __ ] el
cheapo and then there's another dude you
know I don't know about you guys but I
always found car engines the second they
turned him sideways and it became
fuel-injected
I don't know what the [ __ ] going on
this guy eric the car guy
you know I'm telling you if you're a
[ __ ] like me if you just watch this guy
after a while you start going like I
could do that I could unplug all that
[ __ ] and yank that engine out of the car
same thing with el cheapo they're just
too [ __ ] awesome channels and I
probably watch just about all of their
videos at this point like
what's-his-face eric the car guy i watch
that guy like the front league an hour i
was worth the videos of 45 minutes with
the videos watching him change a water
pump on a 2002 chevy cavalier or
something i what the hell it was unreal
and but you just keep watching and after
a while i swear to god it's like you
start the you start building your
confidence now there's no [ __ ] way i
would try and do that on my car alright
but some other stuff that outskirts and
going into it a little bit wouldn't be
that bad so there you go alright let's
get back let's get back to the podcast
everybody oh by the way real quick guess
who's gonna be performing in Burbank
California huh
that's the city that Johnny Carson made
famous I'm gonna be at flappers on May
25th and 26th out in Burbank tickets are
going fast to shows Friday to show
Saturday I'd love if you guys come down
and I'm gonna trying out some new stuff
while also playing some classics how
about that you like that you want an
overrated for this week over eight and
underrated he's overrated a napkin
holder napkin holder overrated they
don't [ __ ] work all right you want to
make money selling something for 1995
late at night why don't you come up with
a [ __ ] napkin holder that works all
right it's just a problem if you don't
put enough napkins in there gravity
takes over and they [ __ ] fall out of
the thing so you got to always have to
put too many in there so then as you go
to pull them out they start tearing then
you always got to grab like 40 of them
I'll take one out and stick the other
thing in you might've just leave it in
that plastic hunk of [ __ ] really bill
what are you really mad at now go [ __ ]
yourself this is a rough week for me
you know I got a what am i up to here
how much how much time is left in class
31 minutes all right we're at the
halfway point can I go to the bathroom
can I leave my bobbles no you can't you
have to sit here and listen to me
pontificate about this [ __ ] that I
stopped caring about the third year I
taught it how do high school teachers do
that teach the same material over and
over again you know why don't they
always have their hands in that pockets
you know rubbing their balls trying you
anything just make it more I know
stimulating for him all right bill
you're not stupid is what this called is
what's this called is is what this is
called bill I've been listened to your
podcast for the past two months and I
honestly don't think you're stupid at
all just a mere fact sir that you have
to defend me
you know if the gloves don't fit you
give great advice and it's not just some
hollow cookie cutter [ __ ] I don't
know about your educational background
but you have an excess of common sense
and wisdom if I have an issue I would
definitely bring it to you in hopes that
you have advice for me anyone who thinks
you're [ __ ] is just covering up
their retardation by taking it out on
you keep that [ __ ] up thank you sir you
know what that was all good to your last
two sentences and then everyone just
realized that you had the same intellect
I do which is why you don't think I'm
dumb anyone who thinks you're [ __ ]
is just covering up their retardation by
taking it out on you keep that [ __ ] up
dude you ain't [ __ ] stupid keep that
[ __ ] [ __ ] up I appreciate that sir
all right let's talk sports all right at
the risk of having all the [ __ ]
people who got picked last in gym class
whined to me on toy made somebody yet
another person threatened to unfollow me
on Twitter if I didn't stop tweeting
about sports threatening you know if you
don't stop talking about sports I'm
gonna stop I might stop listening to you
I don't give a [ __ ]
maybe Meryl Streep is right
I think women just unfollow you guys
sitting there they talk about it this is
my prediction for the for the NBA I
think the Spurs are gonna win it all
you know why the Spurs play basketball
the way your dad fights you know he's
your dad is too old to [ __ ] around okay
he's just gonna end it with the [ __ ]
throat chop he's just sitting there
trying to do some Floyd Mayweather [ __ ]
that you saw on TV okay that's what's
happening to the LA Clippers right now I
don't know if they're still even if they
got swept or not it's three three zip
last I saw watching them they would just
do it you know the [ __ ] Clippers
they're out there like trying to throw
[ __ ] alley hoops and [ __ ] goddamn
Spurs are sitting half of a [ __ ] bald
just sitting there picking and rolling
them to death you know every
fourteen-year-old kid at some point
squares off with his dad like all right
I've had enough of your [ __ ] old man
right and what does he do [ __ ] hit
you with some shitty learned in the Navy
and it's over in two seconds you're
sitting there watching the UFC and roll
them around on the mat thinking you know
some [ __ ] you don't all right this is
the thing about old guys they're very
[ __ ] efficient Tim Duncan doesn't
have time for your [ __ ] [ __ ] all
right he's gonna score as many as he
needs to and then he's gonna expression
with no expression on his face he's
gonna walk off the court as you sit
there scratching you young full head of
hair wondering what the [ __ ] just
happened
all right I know a lot of people are
thinking of possibly Oklahoma City who I
love that team but I'm telling you I
think the Spurs are going to do it and
I've actually because I was just in a
part of the country where they weren't
showing any of the huh or I couldn't I
was in a hotel room and I couldn't get
any of the hockey every time I was
working it was on and I missed it but I
kept catching the basketball games and
I've actually NBA hoop was way better
way [ __ ] better than I've been given
it credit for the games have been great
and actually in the end even with the
timeouts and all
file shots there's a ton of drama it is
a great sport you know what it is I
think it's just regular season games
when like Milwaukee's playing [ __ ]
Toronto and they're doing that timeout
timeout [ __ ] I think I judged him on the
regular season which is what a lot of
people do with hockey right who's
kidding hope so my bed all right I have
to apologize for that
NBA hoop is actually the [ __ ] I'm
actually I'm back into it and I really
want to see the Spurs you know throat
Shah Oklahoma City after they finish off
the [ __ ] Lakers and by the way though
how right am I about Pau Gasol have you
ever seen a [ __ ] face like that when
he gets called for a foul or if they are
they I saw one where he didn't touch the
ball and they said it was Oklahoma's
ball because they claimed it went off
him dude his [ __ ] face I'm telling
you and then when he dunks it he's
[ __ ] you know acting like he's in the
wu-tang clan that's not who you are Pau
Gasol Oh am I going to enjoy watching
them [ __ ] loose but even as a Celtics
fan I [ __ ] I love Kobe Bryant that
guy is the [ __ ] I saw the the first
Celtics game you know I'm bandwagon
Celtics I saw Game one
I saw the highlights at the end of Game
two and once again I was working and I
missed three and four I heard the last
game we were up like like 16 and nothing
and still lost the goddamn game so I'm
gonna be watching that one later on
tonight but I'm psyched that the Celtics
and Sixers are playing in the playoffs
just because it takes me back to the
unbeli is underrated for you
underrated Boston Celtics first the
Philadelphia 76ers in the early 80s
those were some of the the greatest Wars
I saw everybody always talked Celtics
Lakers they forget about the Celtics 70s
I remember one year the Sixers were up
three games to one and that was 1981 and
we ended up coming back and we and we
beat him four games to three the next
year they go up again three games to one
then it's three games to two then it's
three games to three
Game seven in the Boston Garden and the
Sixers came in and we're like [ __ ] this
and they beat the Celtics and next I
remember that on that week's Sports
Illustrated the cover was dr. J I still
remember it says Julius James jinx and
they had him Duncan and he had this go
[ __ ] yourself look on his face but the
Sixers I think they lost in the finals
to the Lakers they even made it that far
I can't remember and then the next year
they got Moses Malone and the [ __ ] was
over and that's one of the most
underrated teams of all time as the 1983
Philadelphia 76ers I put that team up
against anybody they asked that's that
classic when they asked Moses Malone
what he thinks gonna happen the playoffs
and he said fo fo-fo I mean and we're
gonna sweep everybody I think they lost
one game that was the other Celtics got
swept by the Milwaukee Bucks to another
underrated team sidney moncrief kid all
right did that bore you did that make
you turn off the goddamn thing
[Music]
alright what are we talking about here
alright interesting subject interesting
situation hey Bill I was dating my
girlfriend for three years since the end
of last summer we had been on and off
one week I say I'm done with her and the
next week I'm taking her out to dinner
alright that's codependent you know what
that just says to me either you're
afraid to be alone or she's [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of you
one of the other we didn't speak for
about a month then I saw her out with a
guy making out with him I lost my cool
and punched the guy I'm usually a
laid-back person but seeing that drove
me crazy I realized that if I continue
to play this game with her I'll lose her
so for the past month I've been great to
her wait time out time out time out
dude you already saw her
in a bar making out with another guy all
right you got to walk away from this one
that this one's over to you guys you get
together you break up you're you're
you're on the outs for a month then
you're back together
you don't want to do this that's like
one of those curtain Cortney [ __ ] Sid
Vicious kind of [ __ ] relationships
you know be you punch this guy in the
face what did that guy do he's doing
what guys is supposed to do he's trying
to get laid he doesn't know you right he
punched the wrong person if you ask me
but you can't punch the leg so you got a
dumper right before you dump or take a
really nice get a really nice camera and
take a picture of a face and then go buy
a heavy bag and just put it on that and
just go to the [ __ ] ribs anyways he
goes I've been great to her dinner's
going out with their parents doing all
the little things that she loves we got
close again so she's been sleeping at my
apartment has been and has been leaving
things here and has been asking if she
can go go to my apartment when I'm not
there dude if she if this story ends
with her banging some dude in your bed
in your apartment
all right then when she sleeps here she
keeps leaving I already said that one
all right
oh then when she sleeps here she keeps
leaving things here in anticipation for
her next sleepover which is usually the
next night one of my problems has always
been that she doesn't give me personal
space so this definitely has been
bothering me also I hate making out in
public and she loves it
I think it's immature and unnecessary
last night we were out with my friends
and she kept like yelling let's make out
and I was so annoyed I said not right
now she then got off my lap and walked
away she was doing little annoying
things like this all night so so I left
so now I am very annoyed with this girl
and I'm definitely back in a I don't
want to see her stage only problem my
mom's wedding is this Thursday and she's
going with me in a
parents are invited so do I pretend that
everything is good and continue to lie
to her and myself and fake that
everything is great
to everybody at this wedding and my
mother or do I man up and go solo to the
wedding and stop faking that this is the
girl for me
yeah he answered you you know what you
got to do you got ya dumper that's it
it's over you know you have a wedding to
go to you wanna have a good time maybe
you'll meet you maybe you see a nice
girl there that you want to be with you
know then you won't be able to go there
and then she you're her whole first vibe
is she's gonna see you this other girl
on you with a scowl on your face and
she's actually gonna feel bad for the
girl because of your energy when you're
the goddamn victim here as far as I'm
concerned yeah dump er dumper make a
list of [ __ ] you have to do today go to
the bank wash your car dump girlfriend
and just [ __ ] just just knock him
right off and just sit down and it's
gonna suck she's either gonna cry she's
gonna yell at you but you know what in a
[ __ ] hour hour and a half it's gonna
be over all right you know what you want
to do talk to El Madrigal al Madrigal
the great al Madrigal the daily show
zone al Madrigal minivan men podcast al
Madrigal you ask him al Madrigal knows
how to break it he should have a [ __ ]
billboard he told me one night these
hilarious stories of when he was gonna
break up with somebody how he went about
it and it was [ __ ] brilliant
he had the element of surprise he was
totally prepared
bing-bang-boom go [ __ ] yourself it was
over it was like it was basically the
same way a corporation fires a longtime
executive the only thing that's missing
with the way L would break up with
somebody with security walking the
person out all right so email al
Madrigal at minivan men just go to that
podcast and you'll see he'll tell you
what to do he'll tell you how to I'm
telling you what to do which I think you
already know and Al will tell you how to
do it
they should really have like courses on
that I don't know why they don't have
that especially for young people when
you just don't know how to do it you
know they should just teach you how to
[ __ ] do it
the most effective way I think I break
I've broken up with girls like every
possible way from just never calling
them again to sitting down and watching
them [ __ ] cry their eyes out which is
the [ __ ] worst - you know getting
dumped myself I've done all of that [ __ ]
I've been the guy where you know you
know I think I'm pulling the trigger and
then she's like well good I don't care I
made out with somebody six months ago
you know and they you know which does
hurt but then also makes you psyched
like okay now I'm definitely doing the
right thing because I had no clue
you're such if if you have the ability
to do something like that and I can't
even pick up on it like yeah your poker
face is too [ __ ] dangerous
so anyways dude that sucks but you're
gonna be psyched when you go to the
wedding and you don't have that [ __ ]
lie tied to your ankle okay my car is
just weird let's make out like that
seems to me and all your friends are
there there's no like emotional
connection to that she just wants to she
just wants to like engage in that act
she sounds like she's sort of like an
exhibitionist a little bit like you know
what that little thing right there you
know what I bet that you could you could
probably round third with her in a bar
if it was crowded enough you know she
was standing up and no one could really
see what was going on she's one of those
girls all right and you know to eat your
own but that's not the mother of your
kids Danny tell us how you met mom well
I was finger banging her at a Denny's
and I was like wow combination is and
these pigs in a blanket this must be the
one fresh off a date hey Bill I'm
writing this directly after getting home
from a date need
to say my depression is higher than
normal I will try to make this as short
as possible in January I met this girl
this lady and we really hit it off we
went out for about two weeks and
everything seemed great then I don't
know where she stops responding to my
texts / calls etc yep that's one way to
do it then five months later she texts
me out of nowhere she's drunk and
pretends like nothing happened she's a
psycho and wants to get together again
mistake we went out tonight and we had
we had fun but the goodbye was fairly
awkward realizing that she's sober and
you're not the person once again I can't
tell if she might be interested
interested in me or if she just bored
and wanted someone around exactly and
any advice for a schmuck like me any
advice for schmuck like me I don't have
any advice I have a compliment all right
you actually know what's going on and
that's a huge thing all right
look this girl is wherever she is in her
life and that's not your fault you went
out on this date with sincerity in your
heart okay see you're not a schmuck
all right you're a patsy no kidding
I just pictured Lee Harvey Oswald
walking into the you walking in like Lee
Harvey Oswald into the [ __ ] police
station with that big knot in your eye
oh so on the patsy so ah I get it
I'm the guy that this is all getting
blamed on dude this isn't you do you
like this girl you thought it was great
she hurt you when she didn't text you
back five months later she texts you
again and you got excited
then she went out with you because she's
trying to figure herself out and she
keeps you know coming back into your
life you know just take take comfort in
this know that she's miserable and
lonely too all right you guys aren't
right for each other and you're not a
schmuck you're a good guy all right you
didn't go out there thinking like I'm
gonna [ __ ] this chick you know and blah
blah blah and all that evil crap that
guys usually think you went out there
because you actually liked her you're a
good guy and there's nothing wrong with
that okay someday you're gonna meet the
right girl this one isn't it but you're
not a schmuck
all right just stop looking down at the
ground you know staring at your [ __ ]
shoes there's other girls all right [ __ ]
her how's that huh tell me your friends
are gonna give you better advice than
that
all right where the hell am I why does
it keep [ __ ] doing that I swear to
god I'm the worst with this [ __ ] all
right let's let's get to the all right
stamps calm everybody I think you guys
have this copy memorized at this point I
actually just just uh just to let you
guys know I I have gotten word that they
are gonna update their copy soon all
right but just because they haven't
updated that copy doesn't mean that this
isn't a fine fine example of American
ingenuity
stamps.com everybody do you hate going
to the post office do you not like
standing in lines do you don't like
smelling the blue wig of the old person
in front of you would it be great if you
could somehow bring the post office into
your own apartment you know your tented
village your waterlogged head I don't
know why you just I don't know I know
what the hell I'm talking about now
stamps calm you can do you can do so
much more with any meter and a fraction
of a cost you can buy and print official
US stamps using just your computer and
printer it's so easy and convenient and
the best part with stamps com you'll
never have to go to the post office
again and that's true you got this you
got a scale to weigh anything that you
want to ship right if you got envelopes
anything you can print out the postage
for the box and you can print out all
the stamps all right I use stamps com
it's how I send out all my DVDs it's
phenomenal
so if you want a special offer right now
I got a special offer use my last name
ber b you are r for a no risk trial plus
110 dollar bonus offer that includes a
digital scale and fifty-five dollars of
free postage that's enough month that's
enough postage to mail everybody that
you hate and to tell them what you
really feel about them all right don't
wait go to stamps calm now before you do
anything else you click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Burpee URR that
stamps.com interbirth alright okay now
where do we go from here you know what
I'm gonna do this week ladies and
gentlemen I'm gonna go see the dictator
and I'm gonna do a bunch of [ __ ]
stand-up I'm really excited about
putting my new hour together and for the
first time in a long time I actually sat
down and wrote wrote out some ideas I
think I want to try to do just like a
new like 20 minutes chunk like some of
the [ __ ] I've been working on and just
tell a couple of stories what did I want
to talk about I'm gonna talk about sex
scenes in movies and why I think they're
stupid and that might lead into
something I don't know what I don't know
where I'm gonna go with this hour I mean
I can't really just sit here am I really
gonna dedicate another [ __ ] 20
minutes to ragging on relationships
there's got to be there's got to be an a
left turn in there somewhere you know
I'm trying out new [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
trying to rebuild this goddamn
carburetor just got the parts the other
day you know what here's a question for
all you gear heads out there I'm trying
to get I got the I got the what do you
call it the Jesus I don't what the [ __ ]
it's called the fuel bowl you know they
got the primary in the secondary I can
get both of those off but then there's
that next piece that's behind it you
know up against the basically the main
body of the carburetor and I know
there's a gasket on the other side of
that and this thing is really old and
it's a piece of [ __ ] so it's really
stuck there so I got a small screwdriver
I'm sort of tapping at it but I'm
worried that I'm gonna do damage to the
metal and I'm gonna have to get it
machined if you have any ideas on how to
[ __ ] get it off I don't want to
damage the carburetor but this is the
thing about doing all that type of stuff
is there's really no comedy and science
it's just so [ __ ] you know reading
about the elements and everything I
guess the comedy is how [ __ ] stupid
or blows your mind or whatever but like
I don't know I think in a year's time
I'm gonna do like four years worth of
science classes because I've become
obsessed with it like my birthday's
coming up and I asked Nia to get me this
book on like just electrical you know
for houses and that type of stuff
because electricity is [ __ ] magic to
me I don't understand it at all then I
just watched a couple of YouTube videos
and I kind of I kind of get it now like
I didn't understand like like this just
a power source and all the wires are are
just bringing that electricity I you
know I don't know that's basic to you
guys all right go [ __ ] yourself when I
give you [ __ ] if you did know how to
write a joke I never even thought about
any of this stuff why does he keep
signing me out of my [ __ ] goddamn
account sign back in what is the [ __ ]
problem anyways but I was watching that
eric the car guy and he was trying to
figure out you know why you know the
dome light in his car was [ __ ] up and
and I watched him just take that thing
off on the side of the car and it's just
a little fuse in there and it's just how
the whole thing works and it actually it
started to make sense speaking of eric
the car guy he just uploaded another one
eric the car guy just uploaded another
video a chevy tahoe rear shoe
replacement I'm such a [ __ ] psycho I
literally want to get I want to learn
how to weld I wanna learn how to do all
this [ __ ] all this [ __ ] that I don't
know my whole [ __ ] life I watched
these guys I respected what they did but
I always thought like you know remember
the kids who took shop class
you know they were [ __ ] up and every
other clap maybe they just had a gift I
have no idea you know what it is you
just feel like such a [ __ ] as a guy
when you have to bring you know have
somebody come up like you know what this
one actually sometimes I just tap out
like I got to get some screens for a
window one of the windows has like an
arch on it so they go oh you got to make
like a cardboard cutout of it to measure
it like that I'm like I'm not
[ __ ] doing that just come over and do
it sometimes you just gotta tap out you
know like when it comes to dinner I can
make dinner but you know you just got
tell you give you your woman to go in
there and make it go in there and make
me a [ __ ] sandwich you know what I
mean that's why you're here
I kill it and then you make it except I
don't have to kill it anymore if
somebody kills it for me but I you know
I bought it it's the same goddamn thing
now I'm like I'm like the kingpin you
know I got this fleet of hitmen killing
cows and [ __ ] chickens and that type
of [ __ ] and then they bring it to me
you know like Al Pacino I take a to
myself right so go in there and prepare
it
that's not sexist is it um all right
let's talk about some dates they have
coming up everybody this is my whirlwind
tour of cities San Jose June 15th
to the 16th working with Sacramento's
own chelsea peretti Ontario California
I'm gonna be at The Improv Inland Empire
June 29th 30th and July 1st
they Hampton Beach ballroom casino July
14th in the Newport Yacht enseña in
Newport Rhode Island July 15th
don't let that yachting Center name
scare you like it's like a 40,000 dollar
plate for Obama's campaign and
everybody's gonna be there wearing
tuxedos it's not gonna be like that it's
a giant tent in a parking lot in Newport
Rhode Island all right you get to be
able to go down there and be just as
dumb and [ __ ] did you would be in any
other place all right so please come
down to that and let me actually look up
I got a couple others I got one in
Charlotte and one in Jacksonville
Florida that I haven't put up yet so I'm
going to search for this email if you
guys could just be patient oh and I got
Cincinnati coming up there you go
October 19th and 20th I'm
to be at go bananas in Cincinnati bear
with me bear with me I'm uh blowing
through here where elsewhere out the
comedy Zone in Jacksonville Florida
September 27th 28th and 29th going to
the Jaguar game on that Sunday and I'm
going to the Pittsburgh Steelers
Cincinnati Bengals game on the other one
and then the comedy zone Charlotte North
Carolina
September 13th 14th and 15th going to
the Carolina Panther game that's Sunday
you like that see that's how I do the
road doesn't have to be miserable people
um all right do we have anything left I
feel like I'm coming up short
it's [ __ ] guys gonna be here any
minute with the goddamn screens Oh 58
minutes I can tap off I can leave um all
right you're not stupid I already read
that oh here's something here's
something a buddy of mine came up with
and this has nothing to do with
advertising this is a friend of mine
he's trying to get a an iphone
application he made this new iPhone
application it's uh it's called
worden air wor di and AI Ari
worden air it's a reverse dictionary so
if you're thinking like you know what's
a word for air it'll give you a
comprehensive list God knows I could use
something like that because I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right is that the
podcast for this week I think it is I
got a couple more uh anything else that
was going on in my life that I wanted to
talk about I'll get my truck back today
after talking all that [ __ ] about
learning how to fix stuff
I problems with my brakes and that's not
something I'm gonna try and do myself
I'll [ __ ] was something that that after
I [ __ ] with it might not make my truck
start I'll [ __ ] with something like that
like I actually at this point would have
the balls to try and change a head
gasket to put in a new head gasket you
know my engine I think you know what do
I have to do I just take off the the air
filter housing you know
take off the carburetor off the manifold
right then I imagine this some other
[ __ ] that's in the way but as long as I
take it off whatever I probably [ __ ] it
up but the bottom line is nobody would
get killed but when you're talking
breaks and that type of [ __ ] there's no
[ __ ] way I'm doing that myself
I'm going to that way the very least
would have to have somebody there so I'm
actually getting my truck back today but
yes I do feel like a little bit of a
[ __ ] because I didn't figure it out
myself but you know [ __ ] you I'm trying
you know what the thing about it is when
you first start to learn how to fix
things is the hardest thing I find is
not having the balls to just start
taking it apart it's it's the overhead
the amount of [ __ ] money you have to
spend in tools but once you buy and he
got him forever man oh and speaking of
which remember I bragged that I fixed a
blender it's [ __ ] up all the lights
are coming on I don't know what I did to
it but uh I'm gonna quit underrated
overrate underrated for this week
overrated [ __ ] voicemails leaving
them is the most awkward thing I've
always said that I'm terrible at leaving
them but whenever I say that everyone
else whenever I say that everyone else
always says it too so I'm putting my
foot down on the issue and calling it
right now leaving a message for someone
on the phone sucks
there's no way to start your message
normally without sounding like a douche
and then five minutes later you realize
you've been trailing on and on while
saying too many times making you want to
kill yourself ending with the inevitable
okay thanks bye reminding them that you
still a douche [ __ ] awful dude this
is something that's really like an
epidemic in this young generation is
everybody just feeling awkward and
feeling like a douche I don't know what
happened to you guys I think this last
generation of fathers they flipped like
I'm not gonna beat the [ __ ] out of my
kid not hug them and never tell them
that I that I that I love them you know
I'm gonna do all of that [ __ ] and you
end up with these people who can't even
[ __ ] leave voicemails what is so
awkward
you know I I you know what I have a hard
time getting off the phone I forget I
forget what I used to say but I don't
feel awkward but I just feel like an
idiot I guess so I guess I kind of
relate I just go I that's it I'm out of
here I will say that believing a message
I like leaving messages I sing on
people's voicemails you know whenever I
call up [ __ ] Bobby Bobby Kelly or
[ __ ] Joey roses I call him up and
I'll just immediately I'll just whatever
comes my mind I'll just start singing
who's the [ __ ] that I love the most
who's that [ __ ] who eats the toast
it's Joey he's such a big [ __ ] to Rosa
what's going on it's bill give me a call
back you [ __ ] click that's it why don't
you try singing can you do it for
anybody hey mom what's up you sweetie
thanks for having me 40 years ago I sent
you some flowers you didn't call me
do you like my siblings better than me
click right why don't you do that try
that sir try singing first all right
underrated overrated underrated sitting
down to pee if you're a guy is it that
how old are you is it that hard to stand
up what is wrong with this [ __ ]
generation of guys you know sitting down
to pee it's actually easier and you
don't get varicose veins from all those
years and Stan there's nothing better
than just pulling out your dick and just
[ __ ] peeing all over everything
you know you [ __ ] shooting the toilet
paper around it's [ __ ] good time
anyways says the guy who drives a
[ __ ] hybrid anyways there are many
benefits to being a guy and sitting down
to pee such as not having to hear your
chick can play
about peeing on the seat even though
it's on the [ __ ] top of the bowl and
it's not actually the seat yeah here's a
guy he's literally sitting down to pee
so his girlfriend will stop yelling at
him okay I don't know what happened
people a hundred years ago we could hit
him with mop handles and I don't know
what happened they got organized and we
didn't and now we're sitting down to pee
just so they'll stop yelling at us all
right number two if you like me if
you're like me and you wake up to pee at
night you don't have to [ __ ] with your
eyes and turn on the bathroom lights to
aim
dude you're taking all the fun out of it
that's how you train your ear all right
that sounds like the back of the bowl
where's the water that's the floor there
it is one small step number three not
bending down to lift up the seat oh you
know what dude you're a [ __ ] pansy
not bending down to clean off the seat
less bending in general why don't you
just bend over and suck your own dick is
just sit on the bowl you [ __ ] douche
[ __ ] that guy peeing sitting down you
know what else sir what else is
overrated lifting weights owning a gun
chewing tobacco eating steak what else
drinking scotch smoking cigars fixing
your own car what what else sir what
else is [ __ ] overrated everything
that makes being a guy [ __ ] awesome
losing your [ __ ] because some guy you
don't know missed a field goal that
really has no effect on your life
talking [ __ ] is that all overrated Lee
Marvin
the thing that saved you sirs you didn't
leave your name so that that's the only
thing that I can say is I can at least
see that there was sort of some sort of
shame in your email all right what do we
got here why don't we got here the man
grade I talked about that stamps calm I
did that and oh a Mazon calm everybody
last one
amazon.com if if you guys you know if
you buy stuff on Amazon sure if you want
to support this podcast just go to Bill
burr com
click on the podcast page you'll see the
amazon.com link click on that and then
your right to Amazon you don't have to
do anything else all right and if you
buy something not but if you buy
something they kicked me a percentage it
doesn't cost you any extra money and I
take 10% of that and I give it to the
Wounded Warriors Project that's how it
goes and that's the deal and the last
one
oh sorry gamefly.com all right how would
you like to have 8000 games at your
fingertips delivered right to your door
or right to your PC two-week 15-day free
trial you can play 8000 games for
nothing not a zilch all right
that's worth a one day free trial
they're giving you 15 days just go-to
gamefly.com slash bill burr and you'll
get the other my podcast listeners get
the special offer there you go video
games look like I hooked you up video
games amazon.com post office in your own
house and you'll make a better steak
this weekend what else do you want from
me
you want more don't you well go [ __ ]
yourself because that's the end of this
podcast all right did I forget anything
I don't think I did that is it that is
all and now it's on to Chicago and let's
win there
you